so when you get in the car a car like
this do you talk to it to tell you where
you want to go google says self-driving
cars could change everything about how
people get around especially people like
the elderly who might have a tough time
right now but can't drive anymore John
Kasich he runs a self-driving car
project at Google he wanted to take his
97 year old mother Murray on his bed in
one of these things they invited
BuzzFeed news to come along we decided
it would be a good idea if we brought
one of our own dad's along John Hickman
he's 73 so we could get a second opinion
are we gonna go drive some cars me and
Maria are just getting ready to take our
first rides and a self-driving car Maria
are you excited so you'll see my hands
are not on the steering wheel all right
now we're really just focused on making
sure the cars and drive safely
throughout the world but you know that
it works so far because we're doing here
right she's got her shades on she's
totally ready and she says she wants one
of these for herself as soon as possible
it feels like you're just driving around
with a chauffeur anyway that's a word I
can chew I like my iPhone I got a nice
putt
yeah the right definitely pretty smooth
Murray says she feels more comfortable
than she did when her son-in-law drove
her to Mountain View this morning which
is hilarious John Hickman is definitely
a skeptic know things that
you're not gonna answer my question well
no I'm not but you see you know that
your friend is around the corner and you
want to stop talk to him how do you how
do you override so you can do that
that's that at least is the direct
answer to the question yeah we
definitely had some abrupt swerves John
was not pleased but do you have any
capacity to take this to a foreign city
and a li you know that has no experience
with and turn it lucidum then you move
forward about six feet and the car
nudged out to make sure that the road
was clear yet John was less excited he
asked her a lot of questions about how
fast the car could change course or if
you could possibly take over while
you're driving it actually if a red
light if a traffic light had been
installed this morning and bhisma and
the you guys didn't know about it would
it reckon with the car recognize it so
when you get in the car a car like this
do you talk to it to tell you where you
want to go yep
that's a that's a really good question
and that went way ahead and around the
corner the cars not seeing all that is
in that
show the world your sticker it was quite
interesting I was a little apprehensive
at times because I know 100% trust in
technology like I was in a chauffeured
German
what's your friend say hey Bob that's
why I'm bringing this there they all
wanna ride in the Google